I'm Bill McFarland and I'm the scout master with Troop 8 in Kittsfield, Massachusetts.
This edition of the Scout Masters podcast, sponsored by Packers Like Me.
And now it's the old scout master.
Well, like you, I do my best to try and keep up with all the developments in
the scouting arts and sciences and I make sure to keep abreast of all of the
research work that is being done by brave Scouters in the large
Baden Collider in Zern, Switzerland,
And this comes through this morning. after extensive research,
It has been determined that the number of mosquitoes in a given
location is in inverse proportion to the amount of repellent available.
Sounds right to me.
Another, another mosquito joke.
Okay,
Hey, this is podcast number three hundred and twenty four.
Welcome back to the Scout Master podcast.
This is Clark Green.
Oh, let's take a look at the mailbag.
Jeff Peters is an assistant scout master with Boy Scout Troop 851 in
Ellicott City, Maryland.
So I just read article you posted several years ago called the
overprotected child. you're spot on.
Thanks for all the good work you do with the blog.
Well, thanks, Jeff.
I will put a link to that article in the podcast notes.
It is something to. it is definitely something to think
about, and it's been a while since we looked at that.
Paul Kurzenbach said thanks for posting. all of the information
on the blog is very helpful.
All the best.
Well, thank you, Paul.
Also heard from Greg Brennam who says: I've just come back
from summer camp with a report that all of my new scouts did
the requirements in the Trail to Eagle program for Scout
Tenderfoot, Second Class and First Class rank.
Now do I take the Trail to Eagle director's word for it
and sign off their books?
Do I talk to these scouts and see if they know the
requirements?
That kind of sounds like retesting in my opinion, and
I read about that on your blog and I don't want to do it.
So I'm interested in your thoughts.
These younger scout programs that are very common at camps
nowadays- this is a question that comes up perennially.
What exactly are they doing in those programs and is
participation in those programs a fulfillment of rank
requirements? and based on what I know of the program at
our camp, it is not.
So there are four components to advancement right:
A scout learns, a scout's tested, a scout's reviewed
and a scout is recognized.
So I think it's safe to say when a scout goes through
this kind of program at camp where they cover all of
the requirements between scout and first class that
they maybe, maybe have done step one. a scout has
learned- and I say maybe because think about what's
going on in this kind of program- right,
They are probably part of a very large group.
There's going to be a few instructors and a lot of
scouts. they're at summer camp so they might be paying
attention to what's going on or they might not be.
They may have plenty of time to practice the skills or
to talk about the knowledge required to fulfill
the requirement, or they may not have taken much time
with it at all.
They might have just talked about it and said: well,
you know, on a future camp out or working with
your troop, now you know what to do and then
you'll have the chance to do it and fulfill
the requirement, something like that.
Greg, if you look carefully at the list you were
given or the description of the program, you
probably see that there's some kind of a statement
to the effect that your scouts were at least in the
area when the specific skills were demonstrated
or the knowledge was shared,
Not that they were tested on their acquisition
of the knowledge or competence in the skills.
I know that's made very clear for the program
at our camp.
Scouts who participate in that program are not
completing requirements,
They're just learning about them.
And one thing that we do while we're a camp
is we make sure that our older scouts, our youth
leaders, are aware that they have the opportunity
to sit down with younger scouts during the day
and talk to them about the requirements
that they went over in that program,
And there is possibly times when they'll be able
to sign off some of those requirements right
there at camp.
So that's something that comes up each year
around this time.
So it's a perennial question and I hope that
helps.
Hey, we also heard from Larry Gonzalez, who's a
Scoutmaster in Iwa Beach, Hawaii, and Larry said:
I just started listening to your podcasts in June
and I really love them.
They've given me some great ideas and I will become
a backer and I look forward to contributing to
your work in the future.
Well, thanks so much, Larry.
I did mention that Larry became a backer during
last week's podcast.
You can support the work that I'm doing in a
couple of different ways.
The first is doing what Larry did: become a backer,
and that's like making a one time payment.
Then there's another way to do it, which is to become
a patron, which is making a monthly subscription
payment of $5 or more through a service called
Patreon.
Now, both of these things are fairly easy to do
and there are premiums involved for becoming
a backer or a patron.
Go to any page at scoutmastercgcom and look up.
in the top right hand corner
There's a link that says support and there's
one that says be a patron.
Follow those links, find out what's going to
work for you, become a patron or a backer, and
I'll make sure to thank you personally on
our next podcast.
I do my best to have a couple of live chat
sessions every week.
These are usually Tuesday and Wednesday mornings.
What you do is go over to scoutmastercgcom
and you'll see the live chat link down in the
bottom right hand corner of the page. or keep
an eye on our Facebook feed and our Twitter
feed, because I'll always provide a link through
those so that you can come and join in the chat.
And in addition to all the frequent flyers
that showed up this past week,
George Shields, who's an assistant scoutmaster
with Troop 147 in Knoxville, Tennessee,
stopped in and George had some questions
about starting a venture crew, and sometimes
we talk about helpful and serious
subjects like that, and sometimes we just talk,
And, as I mentioned last week, the podcast
going to be taking a break for the next
few weeks. while I'm off to summer camp
and then on to a high adventure canoe
trip up in Algonquin in Ontario, Canada,
I will queue up some old favorites from past
podcast for you, and we'll be back with
our 325th edition of the Scoutmaster
podcast on Monday, August 22nd.
Now, before we go away on the break, though,
I want to take some time and talk about
the future of scouting, and that's going to
take up the remainder of the podcast.
So let's get started, shall we?
So what is the future of scouting?
I mean, we're busy people, right,
Scouters are busy people.
We may not have a whole lot of time to sit
down and think through what the future is
going to be like, but I think it's an
interesting question to ask, and I'll
start off by saying I'm thoroughly
optimistic about the future of scouting.
Scouting's been around for more than
a century now.
It is such an inherently human endeavor
I think it will survive and thrive
and remain relevant where people value
and understand what it does for young
people.
Our future is going to be partially
defined by our past, isn't it?
I mean, we have to understand what
scouting is and a little bit about
our own history before we can project
into the future and begin to get an idea
of what things will be like.
And when I say scouting here,
I'm not talking about a particular
organization.
Organizations are very mercurial.
Scouting is just what it is.
It's an idea, and the organizations
that we've formed to contain that
idea. well, they can change,
They can come and go, but scouting
will continue on.
And when you boil things down,
scouting is very, very simple.
We have one aim, and that is to develop
character in young people, and one method,
and that is the patrol method.
Everything else, everything else,
is just window dressing, really,
And I know that sounds like a vast
oversimplification, but think about
this for a moment.
Imagine you're taking scouting to
young people anywhere in the world,
Absent any big organization,
absent any resources at all.
The whole thing is going to be
about developing character
in young people by applying
the patrol method.
Doesn't matter what you call
the small group of young people
that you're working with.
you can call it a patrol,
you can call it a Dan,
you can call it a crew, whatever
It's. still, those concepts
are going to be in play and boiled
down to its basic essentials.
That's what scouting is:
Developing character in young people
through applying the patrol method.
I mean, character is the essence
of good citizenship, isn't it
An ideal good citizen
would benefit from and contribute
to the society in which they live?
right,
The most human thing we can do
is to look out for somebody else,
to put their well-being
above that of our own,
And the ideal of goodwill
and family, expanded
beyond our own self-interest,
is at the heart of scouting.
So in this work of developing character
in young people
through the patrol method,
we balance two very important things.
And to shed a little light
on what I mean by that,
I want to go back to 1922,
where Baden Powell spoke
to the Third International Congress
of Moral Education
in Geneva, Switzerland,
And the title of his address
was Education in Love
in Place of Fear.
What a great title, huh?
I mean, that was 94 years ago
and I'll bet you didn't realize
that Baden Powell
was one of the first hippies.
I mean: education in love
in place of fear.
What an interesting concept.
So it's 1922.
It's in the aftermath
of the First World War
And Baden Powell goes to speak
about scouting
as a movement
for world peace.
And Baden Powell's argument
in that address
was that scouting,
when properly understood and applied,
balanced two inherently human tendencies
to foster peaceful cooperation.
In his address
he quoted British educator Edmund Holmes
who said the scout movement
owes its success
to the fact that it makes
due provision for the satisfaction
of two imperious needs
of human nature:
The need to realize one's own self
and the need to work with
and for others.
In the scout philosophy of education
the balance between the claims
of the individual
and of the communal self
is steadily maintained.
To achieve and maintain this balance
should be the primary aim
of all
who are interested in education.
So scouting balances
what Holmes called these
two imperious needs
of man's nature:
to realize one's own self
and the need to work with
and for others.
And when you balance those two things
what do you have?
You have peace, cooperation.
I think if you kind of
look over the last century of scouting
and think about your own scouting experiences,
I think we can agree
that scouting goes awry
when its use is limited
to self-development
or a method of education
or a leadership school.
I mean, our aim is definitely
helping an individual
develop character right,
But that is kind of
wrapped in this interesting paradox.
We develop individual character
by balancing your individual needs
against the needs
of the broader group,
the broader community.
And we do that,
beginning in the patrol,
because we understand
that the greatest benefit
of the service we render to others
is what we derive ourselves
from that service.
That's kind of hard to get sometimes,
because scouting is not about
developing yourself exclusively,
It's about
serving the welfare of others.
So if scouting just becomes
like a merit badge delivery system
or a leadership development school,
if we just focus on those
very limited aspects of things,
we miss the mark.
If we invest in,
I don't know, just having
all kinds of grand events
or cutting edge facilities
or just over-emphasized
learning, the skills of the outdoors,
all of these elements of scouting
that work very well together. in isolation
they kind of throw the balance
of everything off.
So what is the future of scouting?
That's where we started, right.
So if you think about this,
when we speak about the future
we talk in terms of technology,
and no doubt technology
will have a big role in shaping our future.
but there's more than technology
to think about, because
our future is also going to be defined
by the way we relate to each other
and the path that our lives take
and that is shaped by the content
of our character,
and that aspect of humanity
will always shape our future.
So scouting remains relevant.
We form the character
that forms the future.
Now I'm tempted to say something like
in these troubled times
and things like that.
but look,
if you take the past century
and you don't just focus on scouting
but you look at the broader things
that are going on in the world,
there's always been instability
and troubled times.
I mean, there's been two world wars
and there's been all kinds
of cultural upheavals
and socioeconomic upheavals
and political upheavals
and things like that.
and what gives me confidence
in the future
is the consistency
and the reliability of the concepts
that underlie the scouting movement.
So my outlook is optimistic
and pro-topian.
So there's a word you might not have heard before:
pro-topian.
It's an interesting word
that I believe was coined
by the author Kevin Kelly.
Kevin Kelly is always on my reading list.
If you aren't familiar with Kevin's work,
his latest book is titled
The Inevitable Twelve Trends
That Will Shape Our Future,
and I'll throw a link to it
in the podcast notes
if that kind of thing's interest you.
But here's what Kevin has to say
about pro-topia.
Pro-topia is a state
that is better today
than yesterday,
although it might only be a little better-
And so pro-topia
is middle ground
to utopia
and dystopia.
So we're not headed towards utopia,
where everything is sweetness and light,
and we're not headed toward dystopia.
It's more realistic
and measured to say that
our future is pro-topian,
And that idea is a little harder to visualize
because there are as many problems
as benefits in the future
and the complex interaction of working
and broken, as Kevin Kelly says,
is very hard to predict.
And I don't know.
there was just something
in the definition of that term
that I really identified with scouting,
because we have this utopian set of goals
set in front of us
and we know that we have good things happen.
We have bad things happen,
We have an inherent level of chaos
dealing with young people,
But it gives me hope to think
in terms of pro-topia,
because that means
that tomorrow needs to be
just a little bit better than today.
It doesn't have to be utopia.
We may lose a little ground now and again,
but the general trend,
things are getting better.
And listen, I know that we all look
for some kind of assurance
that our future is going to be
even remotely positive,
and that kind of assurance
can be very difficult to find
in the cycle of endlessly bad news
that we seem to be steeped in
from day to day to day.
If you're going to pay attention
to the news
you're probably going to be discouraged.
But if you look at the young people
you're working with and scouting,
I think that lightens things up a little.
I mean, look at the promise
and potential there.
Aim at the heart of the matter
and give these young people
your best effort.
Don't allow the negatives
in the world to define your outlook.
Look at the potential
in the young people
that you're working with.
The future of scouting
is bright and relevant
so long as we understand
what it is
and we apply it
with a lot of optimism.
because scouting is much greater
than a hedge
against the perilous future
or a return to a storied past
that never existed.
It's a transformative
individual journey
following the scout oath and law,
very direct statements
of the virtues and obligations
that have defined stable,
enlightened societies
throughout human history.
That's our pro-topian future
in scouting.
That's what we
scouters get to make happen.
one scout at a time
Isn't that great.
So let's go out
and get with the program
and give it our best.
What do you say
Thanks for listening
to this 324th edition
of the Scout Master Podcast.
Here's how you keep in touch. okay,
Go to scoutmastercgcom
and there you're going to find
all kinds of articles
that we've written
over the past several years,
plus many, many past editions
of the Scout Master Podcast.
while you're there,
you can sign up
to get notifications
of a new article,
a new podcast, by email.
You can join the many folks
who keep up with us
in the vast panorama
of social media.
There are over 14,000 folks
who like Scout Master
blogging on Facebook
and, of course,
at Twitter's. on Twitter
and Pinterest's. on Pinterest,
You can watch us
at Scout Master CG
on YouTube.
But look,
if you can't face Facebook
and Twitter makes you better,
You've no interest
in Pinterest.
You don't put the? U in YouTube.
Well, that's all right,
my friend.
Just zoom into the late 90s
and fire off
a good old-fashioned email.
I'm always available
at Clark
at ScoutMasterCGcom.
That's C-L-A-R-K-E
Now, if all else fails,
what you do is:
the next time you go out camp
and get your magic mirror out,
gather your fellow scouters around,
repeat Scout Master CG
three times in unison
and I will appear
to answer all your questions.
By now,
it should be abundantly clear
that the Scout Master blog
and the Scout Master podcast
are not official publications
of anyone in particular
other than myself.
I am not endorsed or sponsored
by anyone like
the Boy Scouts of America
or any other
scouting organization
for that matter.
No,
I just have a microphone
and access to the web
And I created a podcast
that I hope
lends a hand
to my fellow scouters
and has a little bit of fun
along the way.
And speaking of fun,
here he is
our founder,
Sir Robert Baden-Powell.
Sir Robert,
Good luck to you
and good camping.
Oh, I thank you, sir,
Until next time, everyone.